oh hello I'm happy to have a chance to
talk to you today we had a bit of a run
from our lunch earlier so it's nice to
see everyone regroup from our side our
apologies for being a little bit a
little bit late here we've been having
some meetings over the past what two
years or so discussing an idea of what
became term is computational social
science the original name is allowed to
share that or was the institute for
awesomeness which was a bit more
inspirational perhaps and it's a in its
poetry and I think probably what people
are talking about stomachs this term is
out there is is a great challenge and
it's a challenge for the reasons for
Sandra's pointing to because it brings
in so many different disciplines to look
at problems which are very pressing and
need to be addressed and social science
should have something to say about that
we are thinking about that in a few ways
and I think Duncan started off talking
about issues of problem solving which
had a bit of a discussion earlier on and
in the spirit of this Venus a small
audience having this dialogue continue
through the afternoon is probably
helpful I think problem solving is is
the right things but people want is
fundamentally to have some impact what
many people want is to have some impact
positive impact from their research on
to the edge of the world and sometimes
it may be is a little bit easier for
social scientists to think about that
issue then is to think about solving
problems directly but this is not gonna
be helpful this
alright Sheriff there's nothing
embarrassing which is going to flash
flash on it's a little easier to think
you think about in terms of social
impact it is in terms of a problem
solving directly I want to talk about
something very quickly on forensic
ethics if I had to choose something I
want to talk it that length by would
have been this this this topic but I
want to go back to something which I
know it's been very much discussed in
our group having to dealing with
productivity and organizations itself
and a little bit of touches back upon
some some of the language which people
have been using that has to do the words
of causality and mechanism and how a
social science might bring some ways to
enrich that which we useful for for us
to to discuss we did a study on as I
know some of you have seen this on the
question of whether or not there is bias
in in economics the truth matters we
could have done this in any social
science the only difference between
social scientists who are economics is
that there are more Republicans in
economics and there are those in
sociology I think using the California
data is only I things one out of 49
sociologists is a Republican whereas
quite low for the area of microeconomics
that's one out of three so you get the
variance which is important about it so
uh which is more important so one of the
things we're looking here is to simply
ask the question if we're going to do
things looking at impact and and making
knowledge more useful it's just kind of
revealing people's biases overall in
this in sets do with forensics this is
now big in economics it's making an
accounting it's moving very rapidly it
uses a lot of tools which you wish all
of you are work with this is because you
sense the other data set that you seeing
means it's a federal electoral campaign
contribution where you can code people
for ground truth for being left to right
and then we use this to to get a score
on those renew to be Republican or
Democrat and then to predict what there
were others people who we don't have any
FEC contribution on with what they
actually might might be it might not be
there their politics
so I know this is well known to all of
you I stripped out some pictures I was
going to show you one picture to make
this sense I see Matt by smiling here a
little bit on this not even one
economics likes this by the way it's not
always that poplar to talk about this
but it is relevant you say if you're
going to be you know who's going to be
solving the problems who the technocrats
you're going to be relying upon how and
by astir actually are this is Milton
Friedman he actually looks like a very
nice fellow here you know he's much
maligned and over here is a Christian
Romer I guess she was at Berkeley Allah
before and also person of who's
generally liked so this is not a
personal personal issues is results
provide no support for the process that
tax cuts restrained government spending
indeed the point estimates suggest that
tax cuts increase increased spending so
who do you think might have said that
one
so rumor would be via that one now it's
kind of interesting better ask you
conditioned on and on the name of the of
the author what do you think is the
person who actually gave the quote the
only information you meet you had other
information on this but but probably we
have some reading whether this person is
left or right and we use that in making
an estimate on what they actually
actually do i think the cute thing what
we did was saying does it actually
matter to the policy s miss this is not
an amazing line over here but this is
looks at their at their whether they're
left or right and these are elasticity
which we have lined up correctly so
these are the actual estimates coming
out a regression coming tax policy or
could have been a living wage various
policies as you looked at it says is it
does it actually matter for me to know
whether your left to right unfor casting
your empirical estimates it's not a
beautifully strong relationship but it
does have enough there for certain
fields particular the tax policy it's
actually significant as well now i use
the word significant some of you may
have been quite involved in p hacking
discussions over the over the past few
years look I'm a big thing I don't as
maybe you've been part of this as well
something we did a little bit here I'm
not sure it's funny we report this stuff
whether you should be reporting
significance levels well the differences
between these two lines or not so we're
going to do that here but this is you
know the p-values this is the share of
p-values and this is comes out of people
whose politics are in the middle and
these are the extremes of the politics
over here and there's a slight little we
get round that point 05 there's a little
bit of a diversion the people who are
highly motivated in politics are more
likely to perhaps peacock than those
which are or not you know I'm really
happy to say this is not a light a
left-right sort of your horse race here
although I will perhaps a on the side on
this particular one little bit more of a
problem for the right than it was for a
left but probably not point zero five
significant huh so that was one study we
did on this which is of some interest in
using these these methods and I think
forensic ethics is actually important
for ladies to think about changing the
world because
have to also think about who going to be
the technocrats what are they going to
be giving us advice what kinds of a bias
would be brought into it and can we
detect it that's what we really want is
a minimum is things to be transparent
and people to be accountable I mean
that's probably what we want to look for
as opposed to who's right or wrong and
he's ahead of the head of time we did
something on Panama tax havens as well
I'm sure this real quickly you probably
saw that Panama tax havens stuff came
out we haven't had some older data on
this you know if you never knew where of
tax haven was before you know what it is
now basically you don't you're not
regulated you don't pay no one knows you
got the account you just pay a fee to
the bank for for how it works they
charge only three hundred dollars to the
government unless that one leaks all the
information is a public shop in this
case and then we can take the gravity
equation which is a nice physics derived
equation take the residuals off that and
using a minimum spanning tree looking at
the various hub it's easily these are
the hubs which have too much going on
this is not for this or taxpayers really
on this I chose this being more
sensational this is on migration
patterns so you can kind of see the
pattern into particularly Europe aware
of what countries are being fed to from
outside of Europe as entry points into
into Europe itself not an amazing use of
analytics on this but still quite
addressed interesting if you know Europe
that these are the these are quite
critical points and also Lithuania comes
up as being as being important
particularly for those who are from the
former russian soviet orbit so just an
example of forensic ethics and how it
can be used in this in this line of work
and i think it's an area where it's
we're flaking on on what can be
contributed from this from the social
sciences using a pretty standard tool
kit with a little bit of analytics a
data to it mmm johanna makeup ready so
what is the complete
that figure this is just what this is
just a descriptive map of where the
flows of immigrants are coming from to
which countries and through which ports
were the main points of entry into that
you know into into year for example
duque or elsewhere it's purely
descriptive these are people right but
we did we do this for if we do this also
for trade use for investment it's more
standard but you can do this for
migration as well right this is this is
the residual coming off a gravity
equation now apply to uh to immigration
track so what does that do it tax
cadence you know I guess it's yeah I
don't blame you guys the earlier the
earlier ones talked about the role of
tax havens they don't play much a role
here except that there seems to be some
migration from the you the UK so tax
havens is not the key the key thing here
it has to do more just the geographic
pattern on that let's turn the
proactively puzzle which i think is what
you want to spend more time on and I
wanted to do this to come to something
which is a little tricky to bridge the
Empress I'm represent a simulation
usually I do simulations with data I use
the data to simulate from that this is
going to be a pure simulation I'm doing
this a little in the spirit of a
something with Duncan said very quickly
earlier on and that is kind of one of
the missing elements of knowledge if you
wish despite the incentives are getting
a correct has to do with making
organizations more productive for making
them work actually actually better and
you you know I might since they do work
in a young in a business school as well
as elsewhere you might think i would
take offense by that comment and I do
but the but the truth of matter is
there's a lot of truth to that and you
think there would be more consensus on
what's on what's happening and I want to
get you give you what my when my view is
illustrated through assimilation very
simple simulation because the illustrate
where thinks I think why we get it wrong
so often and has to do through the
concepts of Hamas Felicia heard earlier
and that also of cohesion Jonathan
pabich Duffy ran the MIT auto study
which became the global
sunny and this fits pillows at kearney
at unity Pittsburgh guy named Charles
Reagan but dr. jazz earlier on the so i
think is an amazing amazing guy as long
as you don't take his work as causal but
more is categories being being created
and they've been doing a lot of work
John Palma tickler on productivity our
data here this is proactivity data this
is best average and worst and which you
can see is that there's a lot of
variation across not companies but
across plants this has always been one
of the great puzzles in Oregon in
productivity studies is this is not
terribly surprised it was less
surprising that productivity difference
across firms or they differ across
countries but why should they actually
differ across plants themselves that's
always been a great a great puzzle you
think if you own it you think you'd have
the right to transfer the knowledge is
not a knowledge problem you own the
knowledge it's not property rights
issues which are involved so why why
don't you get his best practices
everywhere emerging in the in the in the
world and this has been an area of a lot
of study and it's and I think we had
still at a fairly primitive level of
understanding of what these issues are
everyone wants to know why don't you
pick up best practices found in the back
of what Matt was talking about earlier
was the same issue why don't people
automatically pick up microfinance could
be an information problem or it could be
some other issue wishes which is
involved why don't people use
fertilizers or why don't people change
it change the way we they do their your
deforming where you see this even in
very modern advanced technology this is
1989 data you can see that there was
particularly bad in the in a new
emerging markets Japan was particularly
low but this changes pretty pretty
rapidly over a period of time this is
ten years later and what you see is that
you look at lower labor hours not
bringing down by region you can see that
the mean fell quite a bit for free if
you which is like everyone kind of
learned what was happening in the
environment so pretty like plants got
more productive
itself and the the end of these samples
are about 60 which which shows you some
of the problems actually doing this
research is getting the the right number
but also points to something else which
i think is really important all this
work was done with cooperation with
people who are doing it ethnography as
well now there may be better ways to do
an ethnography these days like we can
talk about that maybe this time but
there's in this multidisciplinary world
you still know people who actually know
the ground very well and can get the and
get the data so and the in the books
which knocked up earlier you know seeing
like a state I kind of sympathize with
that you kind of have to know the
circumstances of the of the where the
data comes from and often you need a
team a team for that this is another way
to see this in terms of the other
differences and you can see that Japan
is still ahead this is Japan and North
America but the u.s. is not far behind
this this time this is lower is better
in this world it's like golf lower is
better than than high and Europe also
has picked up pretty well but still is
lagging a number of their manufacturing
plants so the general shift but a lot of
things have gotten better what's
interesting is that if you actually
break it down into practices and this is
how it usually works in productivity
studies the way things are done you
break down the practices the practice is
still very a lot for example one most
important things as teams team
production is really important for
example in Europe really hugely
important look at a German production
line teams is the way it's done in the
u.s. is about twenty-five twenty-five
percent so it's huge variation around
this so you would think that there be
convergence in practices to create the
same level of productivity but that's
not what you find you find actually very
often a discrete number a finite number
of different ways of organizing these
areas into coherent coherent bundles so
what's going on and I want to psych you
a study which I think Matt knows has
always puzzled me study done by
colleagues primarily Stafford and then
all Stafford by Nick bloom and other
folks published in the quarterly journal
of economics which is a well-known
journal which they did a 1.8 million
dollar study just give the sight of how
expensive this research actually can be
looking at think 20 plants some which
were treated by consultants so much
we're not going treated buying a sultan
you hear the treatment aspects which are
being of being used and they had 39
practices which they were looking now to
239 is a really big number right so you
think about all the ways you can combine
these practices just on the off on sort
of basis that's really huge and the
number of plants I said you were in was
small but we only we've only tackled a
small number only of observations on a
small amount of that particular space we
should have to have to look at this
giving a sense of how big the problem
actually can't can be now I'm
exaggerating there's probably don't need
39 something less but what's interesting
even though that John Roberts was
involved in is he's amazing economist
and it made tremendous contributions in
the areas of complementarities actually
the amount of they didn't even doing in
it in that in a sense of competence
interactions they did just in a sense of
adding things adding things up this is a
hard problem so if you well look for
hard problems to solve this is a hard
problem to solve beep really important
productivity whether it's health
services or whether it's carp or car
production it's really hard to do this
correctly and involves a lot of
techniques which we know comes out of
machine learning and elsewhere just to
make some some some progress on it I
don't have a lot of time don't do this
kind of quickly to give you a sense of
what I'm doing which is just as well and
and then i'll show you what i think the
actual benefit benefit this is when
you're faced with a lot of data
potentially you have problems the truth
of matter is is that we have very little
data on organizations i'm not going to
go through the history of organization
theory than people who can do that
better or better than me but i will say
there was a time when you thought of
organizations as being hierarchies
particularly you know coming out of
military tradition there was like there
was a general there was staff it was
divided up in various ways this is
called the formal organization biolage
was taught in business schools these
days in organ
theory doesn't rely upon that anymore
and I'm sure students even walk out
knowing where the organizational chart
looks like a very much is why when you
put up a chart of a business group for
example even the even faculty kind of
step back to all that's what it looks
like to actually have cross-ownership in
the world you don't see that anymore the
way they did before instead which too
often tardis social networks which might
overlap with former networks or may not
but that's generally the approach taken
one of the people who do this is a guy
particularly is ron burke and he's made
a lot of major contributions in this in
this in his spirit it's been very
influential usually cross-sectional
analysis looking at for example what
effect is clusters clusters of people
have upon some outcomes such as
promotion of individuals such as gender
equality etc but that's been the spirit
of things which have been have been done
I don't think I'm wrong as saying this
and I wish to embarrass anyone I think
this changed dramatically about 15 years
ago when people start out looking were
at dynamics a lot of that came from from
thinking about networks as graphs and it
came from places outside of the social
sciences itself and it's been very
influential on this but somehow we have
not made a lot of progress in getting
getting getting down to these these
issues itself and some of the
contradictions there's been some
contradictions and also some
disappointments I me just give you an
example this no one is and I like this
paper I know this was a frustration for
Duncan this is a paper which looked at
different topologies I think it was
public goods game which was being played
and said does it matter how you organize
yourself they have to remember for those
of you who come from Bell Labs Babel is
divis what was it um 60 years ago
looking at group structure impacts upon
communication flows and elsewhere but in
terms of this gangs do not find a huge
amount of difference a lot of other
things which are amazing to read in that
article but one of the important things
is that structure itself was not it did
not determine the the the way people
play this particular game the results
were primarily the same across the
various games and this is what this
graph here it actually shows over rounds
they behave behave very very certainly
there's another this is more of a
simulation outright that was an
experiment by this is bye-bye sent Ola
which says look at looking at different
network structures varying them in
various kinds of ways found out there
was not much much much differences in
generals lots of language hear the word
things he says 'no in this space is and
it seems to work only in a very limited
parameter space now think about this
problem think about being it being the
head of an organization and you have to
know how much structure to put in how
much team structure to put in how much
how much of a socialization training you
have to put in and someone says to you
but by the way it only works over a
certain parameter space you get outside
that space it's not going to work that
again is a hard problem it says you
really even if you know you should use
teams how much you should actually be be
using it itself we know a lot from the
work which is cited to you earlier this
matters for things like decision that
people at Twitter data for example on
the new people mobilize for the for the
over the giving for Biafra answer was by
and large no they all signed up that he
thought Biafra starvation is horrible
but they not organized for actually
doing it so what what is missing in top
in this topology which is really
important and what it's missing probably
is that there is a degree of emotional
commitment to these networks such that
when you go into Indian village it
matters to know whether or not you know
the person next to you or not or you can
identify that particular person and not
as to have that kind of a kind of
knowledge or it could be that when you
form a social network we all you all
heard people talked throughout this
morning about this it matters if it's
homophily we just met which whether
we're similar on what dimension was
similar weather academics same field
come from the same country there's a
aspects of a family or degree of
cohesion which United stood as a as a
team it's probably the same thing true
also for mobilizing a large corporation
we're mobilizing even small for small
firms you can form any sort of
pology you want you can read this
something saying Ron Bert's correct you
create these structural holes is to the
centrality and this village those two
people commuting back and forth but it
may not work they won't work as it has
no meaning those people who are actually
engaged in that process Mechanical Turk
experiments are great and we all know
this but for some things it's not going
to work as well because the topology
does not have meaning to the people who
are engaged in it you know I know this
is obvious to all of us but actually
it's very important to think about what
is with us with his means now my
challenge was to take this and to think
about could we actually stuck this into
a simulation box and so weird apparatus
told you right I should be going the
other direction but can we actually
trick assimilation to make it look this
this way and here we want to find is the
sweet spot this what I meant by
unlimited a limited parameter space
certain sweet spot where things are
correct and generate a good topology
which you want to look at and I also say
the fragile your organization's fail all
the time these plants failed many were
sold as at the same time so they have
fragile organizations and it's really
tough as a manager or the number of over
a president of a university or whatever
you want to look at to keep this all
going because of this very limited space
with things actually work work very very
well and then I say something about
scaling at this time at this time for
bidding and everything I have that much
time I'm not going to talk about manski
this is actually is a man ski problem on
this i'm going to say i'm going to say
to you this is nice about assimilation
is that you can you can do a stage one i
call this a dick Disick Disick dixit
like simulation if anyone fits you
should use a stage one you invest in
stage two you play the game the same
thing with with networks Matt talks
about this a lot in his in his textbook
first you form the network and then
afterwards something something happens
which you actually are looking at when
doing this through an agent-based model
my co-authors on this is is a Jessica
yang he was a physics out of heist now
running a social science competition lab
at
and Jerry Kim who is at its my colleague
at Columbia Stage one you take the
social preferences and you generate that
first trying to see whether or not we
can put meaning into a simulation you
know of a formation of a network based
upon preferences the preferences are her
MA filet and cohesion I call them a
monthly to me is socialization that's
what a manager does it is to socialize
and cohesion is teams so it's kind of
anything silly but i'm trying to find
what are the actual organizational
constructs they're representing so
they're not so abstract they actually
say well this is why i might be
meaningful to an organization itself
it's teams and socialization we know
these are important structures to it and
then we do this kind of knowledge
transfer task it's very simple to do
this almost embarrassingly a simple this
all skip this is a blank line of Goldman
Sachs guys are from the West Coast you
probably don't even know who he is you
know this all the way over into New York
City so but we know who he is especially
if you come from Columbia University of
a business school and these are the and
these are the teams which are being are
being formed over over here actually
matta is how you can pose these teams on
when I'm not getting into how you choose
them I'm learning this it happen
naturally the way I do it in this one
here is I serve as a a person one person
to there are four traits they can do 10
s that Emily's measured how many how
many common traits do you have the same
value value on so that's what I'm
awfully measure itself this is example
monthly is an infinity you've got this
perfect matching over here when it's
zero you've got no matching at all
between them and then you have
intermediate you have some which are
matched and some which are standing out
a loan so it's in between the two the
two of the two of them the other one we
are and this forms by the way these
various values Sun which is really nasty
which is a very modular structure which
has very very low diversity exchange
possibilities this would be a bad thing
because how can you exchange between the
structures themselves over here is ran
everyone's connected so it has been no
particular structure what whatsoever and
then one in between is probably going to
be something which is closer to the
sweet spot which is what we're actually
looking for cohesion is teens these are
friends of friends usually forming
triangles of some sort and they end up
for these are the values we should take
alpha is alpha 0 here alpha is infinity
no triangles whatsoever and then we have
something in between and you can see the
network structures which are formed
random you don't seem too many triangles
going on when it's very cohesive you
find a lot of triangles commander
structures here and over here you find
something in between this is very close
to a small world because in small world
you always faced this problem of things
breaking up and this actually fragments
the network as well it's just two two
aspects where she chose we could have
chosen other ones is the ones we chose
to actually actually work with in this
in this story now what do i do I don't
have time to do all this very well so I
want you to take my word for this that
we kind of do this correctly okay now
posted i'll post this up and some of the
stuff comes pricing how much this here
comes from a great book and a thesis
which is straight from Solaria out of
drunken wats I know I embarrass him you
know on this but this is actually was a
great idea which was left and I've
sitting there I'm happy to to pluck it
up and make it and make it work for this
one here and I'm awfully maybe came up a
little bit a little bit later not sure
why that happened but I can't seem to
get I was at the airport I can't seem to
get the airport off my screen here so
so what's interesting here is that we
can do we're going to vary we're going
to vary H I'm awfully or you're very
alpha these two things correct and then
we're going to look at back there taking
a small world one here now just for we
don't have to do this but we did we I
thought this might be fitting well
length and clustering so you all know
those those the statistics and what's
interesting is you get to get around
certain values I want to say this with
hesitation you get some property of
emergence coming on now I think somebody
haven't talked about maybe we don't like
that very much but it's something one
reasons we get excited by topologies is
that is a qualitative change in things
which makes which means that there is
this parameter space not only matters in
that sweet spot begins behave very
differently as well so all of a sudden
you get things moving towards your
higher order lengths or or higher
clustering cosmic clustering values it
happens in both of these things so when
you plot it out in a small world ratio
which is clustering over over over
length you can actually applaud out that
that area and just look how narrow that
space is over there now I have no this
isn't I have no natural metric I have no
data here I don't know if this is over
here is totally you know too far away to
be to be verte you know interesting or
not but it makes my point that it's over
a very small space okay on these
parameter estimates the final we look at
complementarity which just means do
these things work together very well it
was just a cover Roberts Roberts thing
and we find out that the art you have a
very small commentary value we hate take
up the cross partial here to show how
that how that works but that's not a
major result in the in the paper this is
stage one we created apology we vary the
by varying the homily and the alphas we
identified sweet spot in the in the in
the simulation and then we actually move
to look at a very simple sort of
transfer of knowledge on this so here we
use something which is comes out of
biology is the fitness thing we randomly
assign fitness values to these nodes
this is not a a regular graph this is
not I can NK graph for those people who
follow that stuff that is sometimes used
in or
zation of theory literature the
mechanism of signing Fitness is this
simply means we take we sign randomly
these these values to these zero ones
here we I think we have here we just
chose for as an example and we get a
estimated fitness at point four or five
okay and then we're going to do is we
can sign up to each one of the graphs
and then for all four of these graphs
we're going to ask how quickly is is
knowledge transferred before you get to
a steady a steady state this is the pure
structural model trace very silly over
here you got one which is zero a little
bit different this is point zero seven
that's got point zero eight you know who
are you going to learn from you're going
to learn from the one next to you but is
you're just choosing on looking looking
to your nearest the nearest neighbor the
only thing we're asking here does it
does a topology matter to the transfer
itself in some in some way and we do
this by by kind of running this race
this is the this is kind of the mark off
you know steps until you get some sort
of of a steady state and what's we take
the max more world value that's that
little space we saw earlier and we find
out that actually performs pretty well
but random does very well as well it's
not surprising that random does well
because random is what always achieve
very short path lines in these in these
are these models so things are mixed
very very very quickly so but you have
to ask the question what does it mean to
have a random organization and it's not
particularly a it have an end case but
it gives us some insight into what
actually is occurring what actually
drives the value of these these
structures we do one more thing on this
where we looked at homophily why him
Moffitt is bad because because a mafia
diversity reduces diversity the verse is
so important to these simulations
organizations of private organizations
in general and cohesion fragments them
so they don't do well by themselves they
always do well in terms of some mixture
of the other two we look at the final
one is on the social one nervous traits
are similar to foco knows traits or
neighbors neighbors are similar to the
focal neighbors on the
you can borrow from those who are more
similar to you it seems to be silly to
say once you form the stage one topology
there's no longer any effect of hemali
or cohesion on what people actually do
as if you turn off this is actually the
mass key problem a little bit this
influence of the structure which has
happened before the structures been
formed but how can you can't just turn
off the helm awfully that's still going
on as well you're trying to sort through
these actual 222 things so we run this
one small world does much better when
you have a little bit of social going on
going on now I'm going to make one less
observation I'll stop I want to say
something it's not as the small worlds
the best of the best thing to run
actually the other ones you can choose
which actually do better it's not like
an axial raw tit for tat sort of contest
here which is this one I just chose
something which are all familiar with to
make the points more more MORE clitoris
social mechanism runs this way you can
see the very minor graphical model
forgive me Michael for saying that and
you see how that might have different
causal calls or aspects to it as well
and the last thing did is looking at
size and sociality I felt this was kind
of interesting as as organizations get
larger what happens to their performance
and how do you maintain high performance
as organizations to get larger how do
you scale up an organization itself and
maybe this is not surprising if it's
just looking at the small world aspects
you can see that for homophily and for
alpha in both cases as you move to
larger and larger organization sizes
that you have to have more himali yet
that more socialization kind of makes
sense I'm not sure why that came out his
result on that you know it's trying to
get that off this morning but I was I
domestic setting a room of computer
scientists i might ask for some help on
this so you know and then also on the
also in the areas of the of the of alpha
you get some effects as well in terms of
you have more largest sizes requires
or cohesion on this as well and also for
performance when with stage 1 stage 2
stage 1 stage 2 you get better
performance but requires higher levels
of home awfully in order to do that that
means that the CEO wherever it is it has
to think even more carefully about
socialization and pulling these people
together actually to work together and
they're in there in their thing I'm not
gonna talk about causality us include
we're trying to build in assimilation
why the social proceeds the structural
how that actually works kind of capture
that a little bit in the network trying
to say there's a sweet spot that's why
it's so difficult actually to organize
these organizations we identified a
sweet spot to make it work and their
issues in terms of the limited parameter
space which i think is a nice metaphor
for y so hard actually to lead
successful organizations thanks very
much